[Musique]
c'est le mec qui monte il s'appelle
Fabien Roussel c'est le des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle pour le
tout fait pour faire
parce que il y a une responsabilité
quand on refuse de se vacciner j'entends
que sa chambre et c'est vrai
au micro c'est le nom du nouveau variant
découvert en Afrique du Sud
potentiellement plus contagieux que le
virus actuel il a qui est les
gouvernements on parle de ce variant
qui est l'Afrique du Sud y a toujours
l'enjeu la vaccination sur le plan
planétaire tant qu'on aura pas également
fait reculer la covit partout dans le
monde c'est à cause de cela d'ailleurs
que vont continuer à apparaître des
variant qui comme peut-être je le
souhaite pas celui du Sud résistant plus
résistant au vaccin temps que l'on nous
tant qu'il n'y aura pas de vaccination
généralisée de l'ensemble des papes il y
aura toujours ce risque immédiatement
classe est préoccupant parle OMS de très
nombreux pays décide et alors de
suspendre les vols vers et depuis
l'Afrique australe je connais encore un
mâle sinon on va rien mais tu les as
pensé que effectivement sa vitesse de
circulation est très fort en Afrique du
Sud dans le monde en Europe donc on peut
plus
d'attente interminable à l' aéroport de
Johannesburg
détente monte en exprès pour faire des
tests PCR au Cap pour des centaines de
voyageurs quitté l'Afrique du Sud tiens
désormais du parcours du combattant nous
allons demander à quiconque qui entrent
au Royaume-Uni un test PCR 48 heures
après leur arrivée et un isolement
jusqu'à ce qu'il fait un test négatif
manifestement s'il arrive à circuler ta
faire sa place dans les pays dans
lesquels il y a déjà une vague de Varian
Delta qui est très contagieux et qu'on
peut contraindre que ce
soit au moins aussi qu'on sache que j'ai
le temps il est pas évidemment une bonne
nouvelle je note contre Delta
entre le delta et celui-ci il y en a eu
10 entre je suppose qu'il en suit les
lettres de l'alphabet grec
les premiers multiples et après la
Belgique le Royaume-Uni la
République tchèque annonce d'une
patiente hospitalisé avec de légers
symptômes les pays durcisse les mesures
d'entrée sur leur territoire mais pas
encore une notification de ce type de
Varian au micro sur le territoire
national mais c'est une question d'heure
très probablement il faut dire les
choses qui circule en Angleterre en
Italie
musique il est probable qu'il est déjà
des dégâts en circulation nous les
identifiants
que c' est dans une certaine mesure au
vaccin actuel et rien à dire encore non
plus qu'il y aurait des cas plus grave
avec se mariant avec la souche Delta que
nous connaissent et
une dame et bien demande à lui parler il
baisse sa fenêtre cette dame lui fait un
doigt d'honneur en lui disant casse-toi
et Éric Zemmour lui réponds par un autre
doigt d'honneur
depuis sa voiture avec son doigt
d'honneur pour que tu t'intéresses au
nord et bien profond vous apprécierez le
chant de la poésie la mue de polémiste
en candidat à la présidentielle ne s'est
pas fait il n'a pas l'air très à l'aise
dans cette dans cette exercice pour le
Président il faut du sang-froid il faut
de la maîtrise et si possible faut un
peu d'élégance parce que le présent
représente les Français manifestement ce
soir trois qualités qui n'appartiennent
pas à Éric Zemmour
qui amuser la galerie
s'amuse
comme si c'était une plaisanterie c'est
pas une plaisanterie
de
fonction autre que celle de candidat à
la présidentielle